why do you think that we've reached this
point where people are afraid to speak
out and people are afraid to say what
they think and to challenge ideas it
started with just more and more
solicitousness towards young people to
not be offended by this and not be
offended by that has that changed comedy
the introduction of social media do you
think people now say things differently
or come and do shows differently or
anything like that it's not just social
media it's the fact that everything is
forever I I think what is uh really
important is not mentioned enough is
that we really are living in a golden
age of community the seller must be
empty because the world is furious that
the seller allowed Louis CK to perform
but actually nothing changed they were
pretending to be much more really
bothered than they were so I say Louis
won a Grammy but it was a secret ballot
I'm sure many of those people who voted
for him would never admit that they
voted formal wouldn't have voted form if
their vote was going to go public but
privately they didn't you know they
didn't care enough not to give them the
Grammy
a comedian starter podcast and start
talking to people that's Brave what the
[__] is going wrong
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is the legendary owner of
the legendary comedy seller here in New
York and I'm walking welcome to
trigonometry man dwarming
do you know what happened there we were
talking about Noam Chomsky all day okay
who's gone completely mental and I said
to Francis I better not [__] up no sir
listen we've been friends for a long
time
um but a lot of people will who are
watching the show will not have any idea
who you are because you're a behind the
scenes kind of guy you don't speak up
too much Etc who are you what's been a
journey through life and also tell us
about the journey through life of the
comedy seller itself because it's a
family thing yeah so okay I'm uh I'm the
owner of the comedy seller I've been the
owner of the comedy sellers since uh
2004 so when my father died
um you wanna know what I did before that
yeah so before that uh I was uh I went
to University of Pennsylvania Law School
uh I passed the bar and then never
practiced law and then I started
people will think I didn't start it but
I started a club called The Cafe wah
which now has a reputation for having
existed all these years but actually the
cafe while originally closed in 1968 it
was the place where Jimi Hendrix and Bob
Dylan anyway I took that name and
restarted a nightclub and I spent like
20 years just on stage playing music
um it was very successful until my
father died and then I had to make some
tough choices and I I sold the cafe wah
and I devoted my time to the commie
seller so that's what I've been doing
ever since and your dad started the
comedy shower my dad started the comedy
seller with another guy named Bill
grunfest who's not in in the picture
down here anymore
um this room was vacant my father was
Israeli he had my father was also a
musician he had a middle eastern
nightclub where the cafe was now and
um this was a room he didn't know what
to do with
and he had like Brazilian musicians down
here and stuff and this guy named Bill
grunfest who's now a Hollywood writer I
think he was head writer on mad about
you for a while
um he came down and had the idea
initially to bring comedians down here
um and he was the house MC for a number
of years and then he left and then my
father's ran it by himself until he died
and just being here as somebody who is a
comedian but also a massive comedy nerd
it I I feel so on and so firstly thank
you but secondly why what do you think
is so special about stand-up comedy why
do you think it it moves people and
people want to travel from across the
country in fact across the world to sit
in a small room with around 120 people
and watch a person on stage saying jokes
well there's a lot of things
um
working backwards in a certain way I
think right now we're in a golden age of
uh stand up comedy quality
I was just
um I'm in the middle of a project now
where I would where I'm digitizing
maybe 500 or 700 VHS tapes
from old shows from the 90s so I've been
watching some of them this morning
and boy is it better now I mean just the
and it's not just that it didn't age
well you can hear the laughs the laughs
are mediocre and people you know it's
just not the same response at all
so part of the reason I think it's like
supply side part of the reason is is
just that comedy is much better now
having said that people always like to
laugh you know it's always stand I mean
um sitcoms humorous things have always
been good
um and people like to go out
you know part of the reason
we're busy here is not just for comedy
it's that it's a place to go with your
friends have drinks get a date whatever
it is so there's there's always that so
all those things together but I I think
what is uh really important that that is
not mentioned enough is that we really
are living in a golden age of comedy in
a way that music in the late 60s and
early 70s like why was music so popular
then but if you realize you go back and
listen to it well actually it really was
an unusual time for music it really was
better than
so I think comedy right now is really
better than it's ever been and that's
creating its its own audience that's so
interesting because people would say
well look we've got cancer culture now
and you know if the fact is that the
Overton window and comedy is shrinking
do you disagree with that
yeah I do disagree with it I mean there
is cancel culture
um
I I've never uh
been uh seen any good empirical data of
how many people are really on board with
cancel culture as opposed to how many
people are simply intimidated by it and
trying to stay out of in its good graces
I mean everybody I know just talks about
being afraid to say the wrong thing
they're very few people I know are
really offended of course
people come to the Comedy Club
mostly don't come here if they're
particularly is particularly easily
offended right so we kind of self-select
I've compared this to um a speakeasy
dream prohibition the people who wanted
you know who were pro-prohibition didn't
show up to the speakeasies the people
who wanted to drink so we could hear the
people who really want to drink
but in general
um look at the people who are huge Rogan
and scholes and all these people on
YouTube
who are it seems like the biggest
comedians all the ones who are not
Towing the line in Castle culture and
the audience is huge look at Chappelle
the whole world is against them but he's
still the biggest comedian in the world
Louie
after all he went through just sold out
Madison Square Garden and won a Grammy
secret ballot buddy MoneyGram
[Laughter]
well what does that tell you one of the
things that I think was a little bit
eye-opening for us coming from the UK
where there's one comedy scene and we
have a different culture when it comes
to freedom of expression in the UK we
don't have a First Amendment or a First
Amendment culture whereas we came here
with our kind of very British views on
these things and talking to you and
seeing you know seeing Rogan's Club in
Austin and we kind of got the sense that
it is a lot Freer here
um and and that that is one of the
things that like we took away from that
trip uh and it seemed like you know we
came to see a show here that wasn't
really an issue the people being
offended and complaining and all that
sort of thing are the rank and file
people in in England
actually offended or I mean you know if
you talk to people who are regular MCS
they will tell you that the number of
people complaining about other about
Comedians and jokes has gone through the
roof really uh yeah in the UK for sure
would that be fair to say yeah I think
so but you don't know what it represents
in terms of actual numbers that's the
thing yeah yeah a number of tweets about
people being offended has gone through a
little bit how many people does it
represent yeah you're not has comedy
changed in other ways in the time that
you've been I mean you say it's a golden
age it's obviously got better but is
there anything else that you notice that
is kind of in in the time that you've
been the custodian out of this place
well it has changed so in in the
digitizing project I like to see it
um I've I came across a Lisa Lampanelli
said you know Lisa Lebanon yeah I know
Lisa and Penelope people might not so
just explain who she is too she was like
a modern day female Don Rickles stuff
making like really harsh in your gut
ethnic jokes and stuff like that
and I went back and listened to it and I
had forgotten just how over the top
these jokes were I don't know I would
have to say she couldn't do that set
anymore yeah even I was like you know
yeah at some point
though I hate to admit it
this stuff does seep into us in some way
not that we're actually offended but
it's just like the the more is changed
the Norms that you just like certain
things you just don't say anymore so
when you hear it it hits you do you
think that's a good thing
no I don't you don't I don't think it's
a good thing no why not
because it's it's false it's it's like a
um something we're trained
I mean like okay so like in um
remember when George Bush had a shoe
thrown at him yeah and we all got the
lesson that well actually if you show
the soul of your shoe to some this is
the ultimate disrespect and Arabs and
Muslim people I knew were horrified to
see this shoe with the president you
know this is a pavlovian response
is that's not a healthy thing because
it's not actually based on anything it's
it's so it may not always be a bad thing
but we'd like to think that our if we
have negative reactions to things which
are actually demonstrably negative not
just something somebody's trained us to
react against so like and and do you
think part of the problem is is that you
know we talk about these big subjects
which are incredibly controversial like
race uh when the covert was happening
covert and it seems that sometimes when
you see a comedian on stage they just
have to mention a word yeah you know
what I just realized maybe I didn't
answer the question you were asking are
you asking is it a good thing that
people are more sensitive to these
things
no no so
um that's that's a tougher question yeah
um because I'm talking about it because
on the one hand I don't want comedy to
get pussified over time and Society to
get possible on the other hand there are
certain things I hear being you know
said or joked about in the 70s and 80s
we're like whoa like I'm glad that's not
happening anymore
well the the the the
um
the most
powerful example that comes to mind is
the way we used to joke about gay people
So Lisa Lampanelli would tell jokes
about
black people stuff like that I don't
know that it was really mocking even
though it might feel marking in time but
it was really Open Season to mock
homosexuals for a long time
and um it's not anymore
I I think because
there was a huge uh Mass insight and
empathy into
uh that changed most many people's views
about being gay
so to the extent that
it's changed because people don't care
to make those jokes anymore because they
feel that it's mean although it's coming
from of course that's a good thing
what wouldn't be good is if all of a
sudden you can't make a joke about
anything gay anymore you can't make a
joke about anything Jewish anymore
because you should be able to joke about
anything
but if if you're not doing it because
you're you realize that you've been mean
or bullying or you know cruel then yeah
of course it's a good thing but no I
mean that's probably why you're torn
right because things are true at the
same time yeah they are true I mean and
also jokes are subjective like I can
make a joke about whatever it may be
let's say Jewish people in my heart I'm
not being anti-Semitic
[Laughter]
well let me tell you no
um but somebody who is in the front or
second row may feel that it's
anti-semitic yeah do you see what I mean
that's the gray area isn't it that we're
all trying to navigate
there's no answer to this but I think
that
um
and I would say to Jewish people yeah
it's way better to err on the side of
being thick-skinned
and um
uh giving people the benefit that you've
got to be view people as innocence of
proven guilty about what their
intentions were
at some point
if it becomes so obvious that somebody
actually is full of hate or anti-semitic
then you might have to say listen you
know I'm just not comfortable with this
anymore but usually that's not the case
usually people are just telling jokes
yeah and so I think sometimes as well is
that
everybody has the thing that they're
particularly sensitive about whatever it
may be your ethnicity religion you know
political views and I think when
somebody makes a joke on that
everybody gets a little bit more touchy
about that thing there's you know first
of all
being Jewish you know this I mean every
among Jews
Jews are making all the same jokes about
Jews that we consider anti-semitic when
they come from non-jewers if you same
thing would get like all the gay Comics
now they make the very same gay jokes
which we used to say how could you can't
make those jokes so
you might say that in some way this is
because there is some grain of Truth to
some stereotypes right I was like
thinking like you ever see one of those
studies where they take zodiac signs and
then or horoscopes and then they mix
them all up and give it to people who
don't correspond to anybody so this is
me exactly it's like a very good proof
that zodiac is [__]
you could not do that with stereotypes
like if I tried to stereotype Jew people
with these Jews are really athletic
great in the NBA what are you talking
about so at some point we have to
probably all acknowledge but there's you
know there's something to these things
that come from somewhere our challenge
is in life to be good people is not to
pretend that's something that's true is
not true is to say despite whatever
may be true aha is calling is to judge
everybody as an individual like that's
really the highest quality right so
you know these jokes
I give people some latitude because if
they're joking about the same kind of
things that I'm observing myself
I have to let that go I'm just you know
like how can I get outraged when I might
I'm the same joke myself
yeah it's such a good you know it's it's
such a good point that we need to have
latitude and also we need to
we we need to accept that not all comedy
is for us specifically yeah you know my
mother's from Venezuela you know there
may be somebody who does a very good
routine about why socialism is great it
doesn't mean that it invalidates my
experience and I may not particularly
like it but if it's crushing in the room
then fair play to them
and another problem is like you know
this is not that dissimilar from these
classic arguments about pornography and
uh um Potter Stewart he said I know when
I see it and that's you know I went to
law school that was mocked
but yet
people still mention that you know
because there's something true about
that
and this applies to being offended or
judging where it's whether somebody is
coming from a good place or a bad place
sometimes you know when you see it and
sometimes you're wrong when you know
when you see it but there are certain
things which are come down to some sort
of deeper human unquantifiable
perception of matters
and that's and then you they'll never be
decided so just can't no let me ask you
this then here you are there's no
problem with you know freedom of
expression in the New York comedy scene
you're doing great people can come and
do the jokes
why do you watch our show why are we
friends how what are you interested in
that's that's brought us here
well the the the fight to
um
be able to talk until you guys are on a
much deeper level than comedy in my
opinion you're fighting to be able to
discuss the ins and outs
of every matter
that comes before
Society
and in so many issues
you're not allowed to do that you're
you're supposed to recite a party line
and
this is vitally important what you guys
are doing so I mean I don't you know you
guys do a lot of stuff on trans stuff
lately
I'd be shocked to find out you're
actually anti-trans in any way we employ
two trans people it should be quite hard
yeah well maybe maybe that's yeah we
beat them every day but apart from that
and we pay them less
yeah
but
um is that too far I don't know I don't
[__] know anymore anyway look you
have to be able to discuss everything
yeah you have to be able to discuss
everything and anything even to find out
that you're wrong yeah and there's
there's a small number of people like
you guys who are brave enough and
intellectually curious enough and smart
enough
to undertake this you know but I I don't
agree I don't think we are brave I don't
think there's anything Brave about what
we do like Brave is you know people go
into combat or people who you know do
have you ever spoken to people who who
are considered Brave in combat they say
the same thing I'm not brave I'm just
doing my you know like the the brave
people but but it is brave in some way
okay then here's the question for you if
we are brave to be raising these issues
yeah what does that say about the
society we live in right if two idiot
comedians start a podcast and start
talking to people that's Brave what the
[__] is going wrong
that's the question isn't it yeah well
most people most people are followers I
mean this is I asked um
yeah
and I I asked him
um do you think you would have the like
I'd seen some uh documentary of people
just going off to enlist after World War
II I said do you think you would have
The Bravery to just go on this to die
you know
and he said um I don't know he said but
history teaches us that actually that
kind of Bravery is a lot more common
than people who are willing to Buck
their peers on ideas that's what he's
you know people just shut up and go
along with stuff
so that just seems to be true it just
there's a small percentage of people who
are wired like you are
and you know we need these people
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests to your questions
access extra content and now the only
place to watch our Roars on catch up is
on locals our wall shows still go out at
7 pm UK time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but
if you want to watch them after this
time then you're gonna need to sign up
to our locals Ross have now become too
spicy to stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
deal on locals
and do you think that things have got
worse when it comes to that as in we you
know more manner or better
as in people were more willing to to
Buck the trend have we become more
Orthodox in our thinking it's got it's
gotten worse it's definitely gotten
worse because
um
it's gotten worse I mean it's almost a
trite thing to say because the left
which always stood for free speech has
now seemed to come come to the opposite
conclusion
and the right
still stands for free speech
but the right is not Progressive right
so they're not gonna you know that so
um it's gotten way worse and when you
when I saw that clip of the in this with
the Stanford law school where they were
shouting down this judge whatever it is
I mean this is not the way law school
was when I went it just was not the way
law school was and why do you think that
is none why do you think that we've
we've reached this point where people
are afraid to speak out and people are
afraid to say what they think and to
challenge ideas
I don't know you have to ask people like
John height or whatever is who really
followed this um piecemeal but
I I think as I gather what they said it
started with just more and more
solicitousness towards young people to
not be offended by this and not be
offended by that
and people we we thought this was just
like part of Youth
but then it didn't they didn't shed it
and it just became more and more a
cultural norm that you just don't talk
this way and you protect people and it's
a kind of a hyper concern for
um
you know marginalized groups or whatever
it is and I really it just became that
way I don't know I don't know it's weird
as well because one of the things that
I've really dislike about one of the
changes that happened is
you know the reason people go people
like doing comedy I feel and playing
sports is that you not quite entirely
correctly but you still you think these
places are meritocracies right and
there's been in my opinion a
Consolidated attack on Merit because as
soon as you start picking people based
on things other than Merit you're you're
attacking Merit right yeah well the
failure of meritocracy
has been
um you know it's a very uncomfortable
issue where that issue where is this
ugly head obviously the what we're
talking about it goes beyond that like
you know but where
where like for instance you know they
have the movement is to stop testing
people
stop testing kids rather than to look
look at in the face of how badly they're
doing
um
yeah I that that's terrible I haven't I
have another theory that um
you know that no movement ever declares
Victory right so they just never the
question so every Civil Rights Movement
just goes on forever and I remember one
time my father once made an offhand
comment that stay with me that every
well everything looks I was it was
mixing music actually and I was focusing
on something and he said well don't
listen to it that way because everything
looks bad under a microscope it always
though that comment always stayed with
me and I think that
you know we look through something in
microscope and it looks ugly this could
be the culture in the 60s and we got rid
of segregation we got rid of this and
you know we changed those and then it
looks good and they say okay let's
double the magnification oh my God look
at that I got and we just keep doubling
the magnification and where to where
like you know 1012 or 2020 or whatever
the magnification now as a culture
and we will always double it to expose
to make it look bad like okay well
that's good there's more so we're we're
somewhere into that endless loop of just
we'll so the things that we're reacting
to viscerally now
we react to them with the same chemical
reactions and the same intensity that we
would have reacted to hoses on black
children trying to go to school
but we're reacting to things which are
almost nothing that we have you told
them back there you're like it's so in
summary that's like a perception problem
we just can't ever say well actually
things are pretty good
you know we will never we just can't do
that no my causes is you know gays or
blacks or Jews or whatever it is and I
will never be satisfied because there's
always I can always double the micro
microscope and I'll always show you
things which look horrible
not I don't know is that and now we can
that's a brilliant magic yeah and now
and this is what I was going to ask you
is now we can make that [__] viral you
stick it on social media and it it gets
out anything like that yeah and it gets
Amplified and one of the things I was
going to ask you about you see you know
hundreds thousands of comedians come
through here one of the shifts I noticed
in my lifetime in politics was when
social media came because prior to
social media debates in the House of
Commons in England right they were all
it was play there was a lot of Play Even
though these two parties disagreed it
was robust debate but there was a kind
of there was a set of rules you know
what I mean and that those rules were
they had there was a decorum there was a
there was no sense that you were here
pandering to a gallery of your own fans
who all whose only interest is that you
destroy the enemy right has that changed
comedy the introduction of social media
do you think people now say things
differently or come and do do shows
differently or anything like that it's
not just social media it's the fact that
everything is forever like everything
right so so in in the 90s if somebody
said something and it happened but
somebody would say something horrible on
stage and the New York Post would
actually pick it up
and for 24 hours people will be talking
about and then the the paper will go in
the garbage
and or maybe this is something like 90s
before then the paper go in the garbage
and the memory Fades and unless you were
going to go to the library and get
microfiche
this just it it goes away nothing goes
away now if you Google somebody whatever
that becomes the top thing that comes
back and I mean I worry about it now I'm
so like well my great grandkids are
going to see what you said about me in a
stupid slate magazine article you know
yeah and and it really bothers me
because people think it's true so
everybody is is very aware now
that everything is forever
and we're grappling with that ever
that's changes everything it just
there's no Half-Life anymore yeah and
also what it does is
it eliminates forgiveness yeah because
you can come out and apologize and we've
seen this numerous times where people
have tried to [__] move yeah and
actually it makes it worse so you're at
the point and I look I believe if you've
dumped something wrong absolutely
absolutely apologize that's vital
otherwise you're never going to be able
to build that bridge again but what's
the point in an apology if it's only
going to make the mob stronger
well what is the point why does somebody
apologize I mean you apologizing for a
strategic reason or you apologize
because you're sorry if you apologize
because you're just sorry then you
should say you're sorry
and um but are you gonna say you're
sorry if it means that the mob is going
to become ever more emboldened and do
more to destroy you yeah maybe not so I
mean you're right so like like Louie
um
in retrospect I wonder I I don't speak
about this but I wonder if like maybe he
should have never admitted and never
said he was sorry because they just used
that against him
um because when you say sorry part of
saying sorry is I guess there's
different scenarios when you the
admission that you've done something
that you could still deny or hasn't been
clear whatever it is
yeah they used to be like you would you
would confess and say well he admitted
it and he said he's sorry like Bill
Clinton when he finally came clean this
worked for him
um it wasn't held again I said yeah now
sometimes
that just backfires
I think when you are already caught
red-handed
if you are actually sorry that probably
doesn't hurt you to say sorry it sounds
like we're getting personal advice
absolutely you can go through different
uh scenarios but there's different times
when the apology I I still think this
times an apology helps you yeah
and sometimes it might also might hurt
you short term
but longer term you will be happy that
you did the right thing and then one of
the things that really stayed with me
from our last conversation because it
helped it helped Joe Rogan it worked
when Joe Rogan all that n-word stuff
came out
his apology was good and it was read as
sincere and I think it really did help
him yeah yeah but he couldn't deny
having said it that's the thing yeah
right because yes forever yeah um and
one of the things that really stayed
with me from the last time we were here
and we went on camera but we were just
chatting was Louis you mentioned him a
couple of times now you had a very
interesting take on that whole thing
that I hadn't really heard from many
people would you would you talk about it
what was what did you what's your record
well my my Rec I don't want to put words
in your mouth but my recollection is you
were kind of like well I think what
Society is grappling with really is the
fact that
there have always been and will always
be people who do bad things and get away
with it because Society does not have
the criminal justice system or the
justice system or whatever is never
going to properly take care of every
situation in which someone did something
they shouldn't have done right
and we have to have a system where we
maximize as much as possible Justice
getting Justice for people who are
victims of something who have been
affected by something but that will
inevitably mean that we have to find a
line where it's like well this was not a
good thing to do but do we just get on
Twitter or in the newspapers and end
someone's career let's say that's how
that was the real conversation and your
my recollection of your take was you
said if this had been a bar person that
I employed who who'd done what who it
was alleged to have done what Louis did
I couldn't fire that person oh yeah so
how are you expecting me not to give
this guy stage time
I thought the whole thing was was
ridiculous in many ways that that
um we all know people who've done things
if I had a bartender who
came and told me you know
10 years ago I was in a violent gang and
um you know we beat this [__] out of
people what I'm you know I'm sorry about
it but I I would I said oh yeah that's
terrible you know but I would I would
never in a million years think well I'm
not you can't work here or you're fired
or whatever it is nobody does that
um
so the notion that
I was supposed to
take action against somebody who had
done something 15 years ago in some
other context without even getting to
the idea that I don't even know what
really happened as conflicting stories
there's no nobody's on the rolls no you
know this we haven't heard anything
right just a few sentences in the New
York Times that I and I knew stuff about
that New York Times article which
um which made it unreliable like I could
tell you that too so yeah I think this
was very much for show
but on the other hand and this goes back
to what we were saying earlier I didn't
know it initially but it had zero effect
on business
Zero Effect on business the the you
would think from the papers
the seller must be empty because the
world is furious that the seller allowed
Louis CK to perform but actually nothing
changed
so there weren't that many people who
were who were that bothered by it
bothered by it enough that they would
stop coming to the comedy seller you
know they may have been bothered by wood
Louis admitted to doing
but you know
they they were they were pretending to
be much more really bothered than they
were that's why I say Louis won a Grammy
but it was a secret ballot I'm sure many
of those people who voted for him would
never admit that they voted formal
wouldn't have voted form if their vote
was going to go public but privately
they didn't you know they didn't care
enough not to give him the Grammy and
and that's the problem though is not
enough people are willing to stand up
and say look I thought about this these
are my opinions and this is why I'm
doing this yeah you know that's a real
issue because if there were more of us
who go look there is Nuance to this
issue to this story to whatever it may
be just because it's gone viral on a
social media platform and everybody's
saying that this person is you know an
abuser whatever else
doesn't mean that's the whole truth well
let me tell you a story about the times
I don't even use this or not use it but
this is when I I interviewed Molina
rizik who I like very much he's the
writer who who wrote that story
and uh originally
um there was a rumor around on
gawker.com I think it was
about these stories about Louis and the
the the rumor was that he had blocked
the door I wouldn't let these
so this was what everybody knew so then
the the story came out and then she
interviewed the the women in question
and it was nothing about this in the
story so I asked her did you ask the
women whether he blocked the door
because that was the part of the story
which was most disturbing because that
could actually be a crime
and she said yeah I did ask them he
didn't block the door
I said well why didn't you write that in
your article she says I didn't think it
was relevant
I said well you would have thought it
was relevant if they had said yes
she said yeah but they said no
this is you could listen it's like so
that immediate like like that's the kind
of thing you don't know what you're
reading
um I mean I was outraged by that and
then later on
uh I was interviewed by the times and
they wanted when Louis came back this
was after he came back and they wanted a
statement for me I said I'll give you my
statement if you promise to run it
verbatim
I'm so stupid she says I don't see any
problem with that no that's not a yes
right
now
so yeah I should but I couldn't so I
gave her my statements listen I don't
get it you know uh Bill Clinton was you
know Monica Lewinsky was just disinvited
from uh this was a from a party remember
that story because uh Bill Clinton was
going to attend and Mike Tyson is
starring on Broadway so I you know these
people are accused of basically the same
thing or worse as Louis yeah so I don't
see any
um I don't see any objective standard
here and I like to
um operate by principles and objective
standards
and I said something like that and she
says if you're going to mention Bill
Clinton we can't run the statement
and I said but that's my answer you want
to know I'm the newsmaker here you want
to know what my reason this is actually
what I'm thinking when you're asking me
why did I do this he said well we're not
going to run it if you're going to use
Bill Clinton
so they rewrote my statement and I and I
signed off on and it doesn't mention
Bill Clinton
but they actually massaged the news
to satisfy them to the extent that you
know I'm I was the news which I must
have been because they wanted you know
the story was about me
people have no idea that this kind of
stuff goes on
but I think they're becoming more aware
of it now though when they've seen how
the mainstream media have not been
honest in a wide variety of different
subjects it's crazy when you think about
it
like they're asking me why did you it
was a it was a a TV show like
Fascination yeah I would have said that
they couldn't have stopped it
just to think
to be a journalist and to think that
it's okay to put your own fingerprints
on the story is such a Corruption of
what journalism is your your fingerprint
should never be on this on the facts of
the story is reported well I mean it's
been my experience that no amount of
faith in in the media survives first
contact with the media I mean and that
seems to be your experience but do you
think that in covering the story like
the big beasts the the Louis CK's of the
world
you know I was actually troubled by what
the revelations were the allegations at
least were to some extent but but
nonetheless it sounds like from your
experience that these are just scalps
these this this is a scalp for the
journalists to get they don't give a
[__] about Louis CK playing here or not
playing her or anything it's just
somebody a big guy that can take down so
they can pin it on the wall uh and just
go we got this guy well you're troubled
by the allegations of course and I mean
I had a big fight with Michael Barbaro
about this and of course he didn't run
that in an interview either where he was
accusing me of blaming the victim I'm
like what are you talking about like
what did you
point to me one thing I've ever said to
blame them of course the allegations are
troubling because they're allegations of
of misbehavior
the the mistake is that to think that we
that we want to embrace
a secondary system of justice a Scarlet
Letter a system of justice where a mob
decides based on New York Times stories
a couple sentences as
biased as what I've been describing to
decide they know what's happened and now
we're going to meet out punishments way
worse than any court of law would ever
have contemplated for what the ice
allegations are
people do things that are bad and
um
that's just the way it is and you you
can't get to the bottom of it
but it's deeper that even if you could
get to the bottom of it
um I am not I don't know I just I don't
feel like I would punish any employee
Louie's not my employee but just you
know for if I found out that they had
done something bad in their life I had
joked you like if everybody does
something bad in their life they should
be ashamed of
were to disappear like that last scene
in Infinity Wars you just see people
everybody like yeah you too yeah like I
never Grandma
but that's reality right people do how
many dudes do we know who have not at
some point in their life
done something they were ashamed of in a
sexual situation
well the woman I was I can't believe I
[__] you know I got character you're
like this is bad I'm not forgiving them
at all not at all not at all I'm just
saying that this is the way human people
are and if something Rises to the level
of a crime
then we have a system for that and that
system you know considers people
innocent so proven guilty and then you
really have to prove that they're guilty
and like I had said to this New York
Times Reporter I see this one little
thing that you spend two sentences on
this could have been like five hours of
testimony from this side from that like
we don't really know all the Nuance of
what we're describing here
certainly not in any way to say and
because of these two sentences nobody
should ever hire this person again they
should become a ward of the state like
you know not even 7-Eleven should hire
them literally they should get a check
from the government and stay home
because this you know and that's you
know they don't follow anything through
their logical consequence because that's
what rage is it's not a you know it's
absolutely and it's not just what roads
for me when I saw that the me too
movement
I made the point which a lot of people
at the time got very upset by and they
were like this is Justice I said no this
is not Justice this is revenge and
revenge and Justice are two very
different things yeah yeah and and
I think that uh
you know the urge for justice
I mean it's righteous in some way but
there's a lot of damage that's
collateral damage that's caused by that
it's just a lot and and of course the
inconsistent application of it is
repulsive I mean it's just report I mean
even seeing it is kind of like with
Clarence Thomas
I don't know the nature of I don't know
if you could follow this you know he has
a rich person who he's friends with who
you know he's taking vacations with him
maybe uh had bought some real estate I
don't know and people are outraged by
this
this is nothing in an objective sense
compared to I'm going to give the vice
president's son million dollars millions
of dollars for a fictitious job
because I know his dad is overseeing the
policies that directly affect me
so everybody's Furious to Clarence
Thomas this very very same people who
you know who are defending like this
this 100 Biden doesn't make policy like
you know so the the application of it is
so inconsistent and you see this over
and over and over again so so Bill
Clinton he's pretty credibly accused of
rape as credibly accuses
you know and you know nobody cares now
the problem is it's all if it's a team
game then people don't give a [__] about
the truth anymore it's about the team
well yeah the people who was who told us
uh um listen lying about sex is
different I don't know if you guys are
old enough this was the Bill Clinton
thing yeah so now of course you know and
that was even a little um glib because
Bill Clinton was accused of lying about
sex but he was lying about sex in the
context of trying to get himself out
from under what was what amounted to a
sexual assault charge from Paula Jones
so he was perjuring himself perjury is a
serious guys perjuring himself
in and this was a matter of evidence
which had been passed recently that this
is considered relevant to these charges
or this kind of lawsuit and um so he
lied about sex in that context and the
very same people who were was you know
that's just lying about sex like and
Trump paid off that mistress and you
know like and and the the hypocrisy is
so rank
and
um
they don't like I don't know do they not
see it in themselves or they don't care
or I I don't know what it is but you're
right it's just it's all team oriented
and this is the danger of one of the
dangers of mob Justice
people who are hated I experience this
in my own organization
people who are dislike never get a fair
Shake that's just the way it is that's
one of the lessons of life and I see it
over and over and over again
and people who are beloved
will always get a pass yeah
and and people who have the right
opinions are going to be judged much
less harshly than those who have the
wrong opinions and may even do a thought
you know a far worse I don't know if
it's the case here but certainly in the
UK the nicer comedian is on stage the
the worst they are off stage and vice
versa oh no no no like if the male all
the male feminists are secretly groping
someone in the green room is how it
tends to work I don't I don't doubt that
at all
I mean Trump is you know he has a
consensual affair with a mistress you
can stop me because yeah yeah yeah
allegedly yes and
um allegedly consensual
I'm pretty sure
so
and people want to see that could could
anybody actually be upset with him about
if it makes no sense but he's hated so
he's never gonna get a fair Shake yeah
and the other thing that upset me about
the Louis thing was people going oh you
know I used to really like him and now I
can never like him again and you just go
when did we want our artists to be
perfect to human beings
artists are flawed like I read an
article in the guardian a few weeks ago
about protests outside of Picasso
exhibition because apparently he wasn't
great with women huh
and you go who cares
yeah listen you know that's the problem
you get sucked into a certain line of
thought and if you follow to his natural
conclusion the the outcomes are just the
Cure becomes worse than the disease I
had a similar experience years ago this
is you know when things weren't like
they were now I had um but this was a
time when when Louis Farrakhan was in
the news for saying Hitler was a great
man or whatever it is like he first came
out that he was you know really an
anti-semite and I had a musician I was
working with who walked in with a
Farrakhan t-shirt
I remember
and and I didn't even
I I couldn't rule out that he was
wearing it on purpose like just like to
to [__] with me a little bit
and everything what am I going to do
about them am I going to make a comment
you know
and I said myself I'll just let it go
like don't be a jerk like who cares like
and then who cares is actually very
constructive now of course
if you if you transplant that today if I
had if I had an employee wore a
Farrakhan t-shirt
and I told him like go change whatever
people be outraged right I'd be but if I
had someone who came in and wore some
sort of uh anti-black t-shirt and I said
it was okay
people would freak out at me for that
too so it's just you know and but
obviously the totally contradictory
they're both basically the same right
he's a vicious Auntie so I'm like this
person's a racist so again they they
they they'll pick and choose they will
they'll well like I said again so so my
attitude is it's just better if we just
let things go I I don't want more laws
but if
if there was a law which forbid business
owners from taking any actions
whatsoever based on the private lives
politics and any sense of their
employees I think that would be great so
I can just say listen I have no choice I
I know they're a Nazi but you know I'm
compelled to to hire Nazis because it's
it's impossible it's an impossible it's
not good but see you cannot you only get
to say that well there's two reasons you
get to say first of all you don't give a
[__] you're on your own club and who
gives a [__] but really the reason you
get to say that is you're Jewish yeah
right uh you can say that a a just a
non-jewish person couldn't say that no
right and that's kind of the world we're
in I think that is and so even those of
us who I think resent the very idea of
identity policy I think it's really
stupid and quite dangerous actually
we're still playing by their rules
aren't we
yeah sometimes it's impossible to get
out from under it yeah
I try to get out from under to my own
home you know my wife's my wife is
Puerto Rican and Indian and uh I but but
my kids are all you know extremely uh
aware of identity and everything and
that's purely from what they're learning
in school and it upsets me you know I
know by you heard the story my daughter
came home in the first grade now my
daughter I don't think she had any idea
that my wife and I were different colors
I don't know what it was like to the
eyes of a first grader but
you've never been any indication that
she understood anything much about race
and she came home and says
daddy you're white right like and I said
yeah she says do you treat people badly
I'm like no what are you talking why do
you ever see daddy treat anybody badly
she says well we learned in school that
that white people treat people badly I
said you learn that white people she
said or maybe that white people used to
treat people badly I like she couldn't
process it
and I wanted to go up to the school and
you know scream bloody murder but I
didn't because I'm a coward because I
know that I'm kind of high profile and
somebody would you know and then I'd go
viral whatever it is it was really
angering my daughter was still believe
in Santa Claus because her mother's not
Jewish
Santa Claus and I don't know to make
themselves feel better
these you know expert Educators think
that they need to start teaching her
stuff at an age where she really can't
comprehend it
this is why I hate this [__] man this is
why they're re-racializing society and
they're brainwashing kids into [__] that
you have to put in their heads for them
to actually a seven or eight year old
doesn't think about race and this
person's this and this person's that and
these people did because they're smarter
than these 30 year old educators
they know not to do that
well you know one of the one of the
things I've said to people in the past
is you know maybe it would be healthy to
start by visualizing where we'd like to
be someday if the goal is to be a non a
society you know multiracial society
that doesn't consider race that
considers race as you know as Sam Harris
once is as inconsequential as hair color
like then
much of what we're doing now is
obviously wrong because there is no path
from what we're doing now to what we
claim we want the eventual outcome even
on the issue of when that issue of
blackface came up I'm not soft on
Blackfish
but there was this thing called you have
little kids who you know want to go as
Black Panther
and
it's kind of tragic in a sense no we
will never let you little kids go as
black panther because we want you to
always be imprisoned to the Past
mocking of black people as blackface
as opposed to maybe at some point we
have to say well okay you know we can
teach about the past but we can also
Embrace a new future where actually
every little kid can dress up as his
Heroes
of whatever color maybe that's naive I
don't know but you'd think that is the
gall right wouldn't that be it's like
wouldn't that be beautiful someday in
the future this didn't matter anymore
and if you're a little if you're a
little white kid loved black panther he
could dress up as black panther for
Halloween no no no no no
we shall never allow that because we
will always want to be in imprisoned by
what happened in the past that doesn't
seem to be smart no it doesn't and one
of the things I one of the things that I
think sums this up beautifully is the
fact we talk about slavery and the West
African slave trade which was obviously
awful but we don't talk about the fact
that we have modern slavery and it
enslaves millions of people all around
the world yeah Coleman Hughes has talked
about that that we're more
psychologically
um uh
obsessed with slavery in the past than
slavery today now of course slavery is
obviously something we need to be
extremely concerned about and and
um
study and and try to untangle
to the extent that it's real how it
still impacts
our history today having said that you
know that doesn't mean that every single
thing which is attributed to slavery is
actually you know because of slavery
yeah yeah and you guys feel like you
have the right to talk about that like
well somebody said that slavery is
responsible for today's economic
Prosperity some economists disagree
let's have a interview with an economist
who has people will call you a racist
it's an empirical issue right yeah well
it it ought to be but it's not and I I
that's I think one of the big problems
in society now is so many things are an
empirical issue but we don't talk about
them in that way at all it's all it's
all about people's feelings and and
emotion and that gets melded into which
is why we're all uncomfortable talking
about it actually all of us because it's
we know that that is not an issue about
which people can be empirical in modern
society I think that's where we've got
to uh we've got about 10 minutes left no
what are your what are your plans for
for the seller you know
what do you see what do you see coming
in culturally and then everyone like
just what are you thinking about well we
just bought a new building around the
corner that used to be a McDonald's and
we're going to open another uh
Club of course in New York
it takes uh uh um it takes forever to
get anything open so we're building a
new club it's gonna take a long time
zooming out I'm very much on this came
from you know the way my father lived
his life I'm very much uh I see
everything that I do is essentially as
trying to enjoy myself and I really
don't distinguish very much between my
work my music my kids whatever it is so
what's in store for me is you know
whatever interests me and
um
and you know money is a is you know a
very fortunate byproduct of everything
that I've done but I'm I consider myself
so fortunate like my father used to say
that most people said no most people
hate their jobs most people can't wait
for the weekend yeah he says never be
one of those people you know so that's
why I didn't become a lawyer and I just
you know every day I just do whatever
I want to do like it makes me happy no
you've seen some of the greatest
comedians in the world come through here
what makes a great comedian
being funny enough
there's no there's no one there it's
like what makes a great music there's no
one thing but um it is it is it it
repetitively you see is like a healthy
dose of Charisma that's a big thing the
same the same exact lines and you know
coming out of two different mouths is
not the same line
um
uh of course you have to be funny
whatever that means
um
and
I I think that although I hate to say
this because it it's you know I hear the
comedians saying it all the time the
audience does read you if you're not uh
honest and true to yourself they they
really can smell a hack
so you do have to be yourself and these
are I think the same general rules that
apply almost to all art forms I don't
think it's Unique to Comedy I remember
reading the first
page of Isaac Stern the famous classical
violence his autobiography and he talks
about his mindset he gets on the stage I
think classical music now is important
to understand this is just notes written
on the page there's no latitude right
there's no ladder there's no like and he
says you have to get out there and you
say you will listen to me and like he
talked about this this
amazingly bold charismatic mindset of a
classical musician like listen to me you
know this is an attitude that um
that performers have in every uh art
form of performance that I think is
common in the successful ones there's
something about them they just
understand about gripping that audience
whatever it takes and when you see you
know people like Patrice O'Neill who
used to who used to Grace your stage
Grace is not young
we had we had a rocky relationship with
Patrice actually yeah how come
um well
Patrice used to if listen
Patrice was a genius
and Patrice is one of the most can I
just stop you there what do you mean by
Patrice was a genius what does that mean
Patrice was a top you know tenth of one
percent insightful person
and he
saw things and spoke honestly about real
things in the human condition that
people were feeling and thinking about
which stayed with people and and I think
um have really stood the test of time
and maybe his his respect has only grown
since he he died
um and the comedians Revere him we do
yeah having said that
you've seen the cold you know was or how
do you pronounce that word like that
is that the right word yeah
um day to day
Patrice was a was a was a more mixed bag
so if Patrice didn't do well
he would take a flamethrower to the room
I mean he would be a you know lay into
people in the audience he did not give a
[__] about
the fact that there was a show that had
to continue for another hour and 15
minutes after he left the stage
and that obviously
caused friction with you know money
grubbing club Owners like me but you
know there's a on top of everything our
Artistry wise in my opinion there is
still a certain social contract that a
performer has with an audience who has
made their plans gotten the babysitter
put down their money and comes and
expects to see your good faith effort to
entertain them
and he was one of those comedians rest
in peace I love the guy who didn't feel
he had to honor that social contract he
said this is about me if I'm not feeling
it or if I'm pissed off I have no
responsibility to the room or the
audience or whatever it is so that was
the nature of our friction but nobody
ever we never I mean he always worked
here and nobody ever thought he wasn't
funny but but wasn't that part of what
made him great yes yes it was and this
is I mean
yeah you can't slice and dice people and
and
oftentimes a negative quality in
somebody is also part of what has made
them successful in contributed to their
positive qualities people there was some
dumb club owner was complaining about
Seinfeld being snooty to him more
sarcastic with him I'm like do you think
Seinfeld would be Seinfeld if he like
you want to take out the essence of
Seinfeld and think that everything you
love about Seinfeld would still exists
this is who he is that's why he's funny
that's that's his sensibility that's why
he became the most successful comedian
in the world and that's why you you got
a little sarcasm in person
so you you can't you can't pick and
choose the Patrice thing was significant
you know it was
there were I think there was a chair
thrown like it was really like when
Patrice went out we were all like
sweating bullets like you know let's
just
I said but we always put him on because
we always recognized
um what a great talent he was there was
a time he didn't perform here for a
while he had a thing with my father or
some sort of fight but that's another
matter and he was very mean to my father
one time and
who were the people who produced the
greatest work on the stage looking back
who are the people that when you saw
them you went wow that's so different
from what anybody else is doing
so different
or brilliant yeah the ones who were
brilliant you know it's it's no
this is the thing it's obvious to
everybody who the brilliant ones are
there's no club owner or Booker who who
has any particularly
deep Insight like when Chappelle was
like 18 or 19 or whatever he was the
first time he came on
and my father said something like this
you would not have needed to speak
English
you could have just been in the room
hearing a foreign gibberish tongue and
said holy [__] that 19 year old must be
something special it's obvious
and all these grades like Jon Stewart
Dave Chappelle Michael Che you know uh
all of them virtually all not not 100 of
all them but almost all of them
I can remember
the first time I saw them because it was
like it it was ingrained in my memory
and that's not just um like I've
forgotten the people it really is
something real I can remember them very
well because they they were just they
cut something into your brain and it's
it may not have been necessarily what
they were saying it's the whole thing
together
and no this is perhaps a sad question to
ask it depends on your answer I suppose
but if you inherited this from your
father who built it up
do you think if your kids were
interested in continuing to run it I'm
not asking about them specifically I'm
asking more about stand-up comedy as a
genre like are people 20 years from now
still going to want to come out and sit
in and have the meat suit experience
sitting here with 120 other strangers
yeah uh and watching a guy on stage or
are they just going to be on their
phones
no I think well let me answer and say
what made me think of uh absolutely I
think that the idea of people wanted to
go out
with human contact live seeing something
real I I don't I think this is human
nature and I don't think it's I don't
think it's going away I really don't
think it's going away as much as
everybody is on their phones now all the
time business is way way busier than
it's ever been
so I I think social contact is is one of
the basic uh human instincts
um I don't know if it's interesting to
you I did not want to take over the
comedy seller because I did not want to
be compared to my father who was a much
a really a larger than life person
so I worry about that for my kids I I
and I I'd already had major success you
know with something I liked doing and
then my father and I kind of had to take
over the comedy seller and I did not I
was not immediately embraced or
respected by the comedians
um and I knew that uh they weren't mean
to me but they're like it's you know
it's the the the the kid taking it over
you know and these this is a group of
people who were by Nature look to make
fun of everything you know so so it was
only after I think that I actually did
made certain moves and expanded the
place and grew the place and various
things where I kind of rose to the
occasion that I think I if I get some
respect now is because I earned it I
don't know necessarily if my kids will
be able to do that
and if they can't it can be
psychologically damaging to them and and
you know there's a lot of
kids out there of famous people or
successful people
who are miserable and just they can
never get out from under the shadow of
their parents Ron Reagan Junior types
you know like you know and I've heard of
them didn't know he existed I think
that's your point yeah oh no he so he
spoke anyway
um so I I so I I want my kids this is
such a fantastic lifestyle like you come
to work and it's fun whatever it is and
the money's good and you meet
interesting people and I would love to
have that I love my kids to have that
for themselves
but I also want them to um
have a certain sense of their own
accomplishments and I don't know how
much room for growth there will be or
what they can do
if they can't accomplish or put their
own uh uh you know what's the word like
put their own stamp on the business they
might never feel that good about it I
don't know
it's been a pleasure it's great was the
answer right because you don't have a
like a dead pen stairs you're like a
comedian always worried about how good
your answer was
um listen it's been a pleasure to chat
we're going to take you to locals where
we ask uh questions from our audience
but before we go there we always end the
main interview with the same question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that you
think we really should be
you know just everybody has to answer
this question yes yes you will answer
the question
well this is you know I I because we've
really talked about the things we should
be talking about I would say that this
is maybe uh not exactly answer your
question but personally
one thing that disturbs me that is not
being adequately spoken about and this
is a very personal matter to me is what
I consider to be the very important
um defenses for the state of Israel
which um
uh young Jewish people and I'm not
excusing whatever things Israel does
wrong but young Jewish people even
intellectual Jewish people
are so ignorant
about the history of that country and
why it's in the predicament that it is
and and how it is tried to extricate
itself from that predicament that they
are
um unable
to have the argument anymore they
basically just nod their head in shame
and I think this is actually dangerous
not only for Israel for the Jewish
people all over the world
and I don't know what can be done about
that but that is something that's on my
mind and this is not to say that Israel
is right about everything
but there is there is something that
needs to be there are things that are
not being said and as they say you know
if you're not for yourself who will be
if Jewish people can't make their own
arguments no one's going to make it for
them and that worries me so what needs
to be said
well I'm not going to go into the whole
you know but like I ask smart young
Jewish people do you know how it is that
Israel came into the occupied
territories
no
like this is like the most fundamental
question about the whole company why is
that territory occupied
do you know about the Clinton uh uh
attempts to make peace do you know what
the second interfato is no they don't
know any of this stuff so in their minds
they've internalized that you know we
are like afrikaners we're we're
apartheid state you know they and um
so like when I went to college I took a
semester abroad in Israel and this was a
perfectly okay thing to do I read
stories all the time now about like kids
of Colombia and I would never think
about taking a semester born in Israel
we have a Jewish star in the in the
window of the Olive Tree upstairs this
has been there my my whole life and
most of my existence this was seen by
the general public as no different than
an Italian flag in a pizzeria nobody
really gave it any thought in recent
years people say to me good for you or
you're taking a stand are you you're
like they're seeing it as it's almost
like a defiant political statement on my
part as opposed to just
it's an ethnic symbol like every every
ethnic restaurant you know it's an
Israeli restaurant every ethnic
restaurant has some sort of ethnic
symbol I don't know Jewish people there
I think symbols are controversial this
is very dangerous I think no no I'm
dwarming dormant
thank you so much my brother I really
recommend people coming if they are over
New York they come and check out and I
have comedy here The Comedy Cellar the
best club some people would argue in the
world I hope so I hope so and some
people would uh thank you so much for
joining us follow us over to locals
where we ask your questions of gnome uh
take care and we'll see you over there
by the way do you think that's a good
thing comedians having opinions and on
serious matters and stuff like that
[Music]
foreign